bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj oggi siamo sul
amber island è un videogame indiehorror
nuovo prima di iniziare un ultima cosa
ho finalmente preso il filtro anti pop
che sarebbe sta roba acquistò cerchio
alchemico che praticamente quando
pronunciò l'api porca [ __ ] roba del
genere non si sente che dà fastidio è di
sicuro le vostre orecchie mi ameranno di
più comunque va beh direi di iniziare
allora andiamo su play allora lamber
island modo i dari che cosa sia me
l'avete consigliato in 50mila anche
questo è ovviamente l'ho fatto perché mi
avete consigliato in tanti allora siamo
naufraghi cazzo sono in mezzo all'oceano
che bello che ho trovato anche una
torcia fantastico dal adesso ditemi che
cazzo ci faccio con una torcia lega non
telefono in mezzo all'oceano c'è
sicuramente campo donato non sto
sentendo l'audio è normale a noi infatti
non è normale perché c'erano le cuffie
abbassate cos'è sta roba
lanciamo il telefono nell'acqua tanto
non serve un cazzo non mi pare che
prende la linea cazzo fondiamo addio che
cazzo siamo partiti di merda siamo
affondati per michael titanic
ok siamo arrivati arriva siamo arrivati
arriva nonostante siamo affondati e
quindi ragazzi hanno su atlantide o
questa non me la spiego comunque raga
siamo attraccati non si sa come dato che
siamo affondati ma non importa created
by the forge mi fa piacere
direi di andare a questo sequel di atti
titanic cazzo queste titanic 2 lamber
island allora siamo a tratti su un'isola
che non si sa come cazzo ci siamo
arrivati
ho sentito un rumore che non mi è
piaciuto un cazzo
che cos'è quello c'è del fuoco
un'edizione sono gli indigeni oddio
cos'è sei stato tu ad accenderlo brutto
stronzo dillo dillo cazzo che sei stato
tu dillo piuttosto non so dirlo
ok bè metti di qua brutto ma adesso sta
in punizione e guarda al fuoco finché
non si spegne ok
ebbene ci sono sacchetti che accendono
il fuoco ed è un problema perché non so
come cazzo fa un orsacchiotto accendere
il fuoco
ok direi di andare avanti la cosa si fa
traumatica ebbene raga non ho idea del
perché mi abbiate consigliato questo
videogame non ne ho proprio la più
pallida idea ma a quanto pare inizia
veramente in modo strano c'è una casa
fantastico raga mi piacciono un casini
nostri posti
e va bene così cosa ho trovato un tacco
dei kings and now with their friends
loro arriveranno ancora non sono sicuro
di quanto io riesco a resistere ma non
venderò mai la mia isola non la mia
terra
ok vai giù per chiudere perfetto vai giù
dove giù dove come si chiude sta roba
vai giù per chiudere e non mi pare che
chiede un cazzo però come ok ce l'ho
fatta bene allora loro arriveranno di
nuovo questo mia tranquilli
addio cos'è che cazzo aiuta cos'è oh mio
dio sa che cos'è sta roba qua donna
torti fa una pippa the cazzo è tremendo
quella fare mi sembra grid con
un'accetta porca [ __ ] via colori mai vi
spiega cos'è quella roba l'hai chiamata
8 molto la star di la verità difendimi
brutto stronzo
tu hai un accetta io ho un orsacchiotto
e vuoi mettere con voi metati contro di
me cazzo aiuto io cosa devo fare
che cazzo no raga e traumatica sta cosa
via via come cup cosa devo fare qui via
via via via via via via via praga c'è un
orsacchiotto ecc e hagrid con un'accetta
cosa devo fare via crema brutto bastardo
crema brutto stronzo rema via devo a
girarlo tipo incontro di wrestling anche
se so che perdo allora brutto bastardo
vuoi giocare sporco gioco sports e
scappiamo brutto stronzo se ce l'ho
fatta credo siamo fatta merda ce l'ho
qui garrett rai che cos'è star mio dio
che cosa stupida che cosa devo fare qui
devo scappare la sto stronzo
qual è l'utilità di sto gioco ditemelo
ditemelo cazzo non sa se ecco è rimasto
di fantasmi
beh allora vado dall'altra parte vai lo
stiamo scappando
ce la stiamo facendo c'è qualcosa c'è
qualcosa di ragazzone a casa dobbiamo
rifugiarci entra
aiuta è ancora lì che mi segue sia
ancora lì che sta arrivando merda
entriamo a petipa ma no cosa chiusa un
cazzo sfonda sfondata brutto bastardo
sfonda prima carrieri tirarci un calcio
case di legno ma si può a sfonda st
porta brutto stronzo sfondo di addio
casa apri apri apri apri apri a graz
l'okay ragazzo è una situazione di merda
aiuto aiuto mi sono preso un accettata
in faccia bene abbiamo iniziato di merda
di reid in inizia allora la gara è una
cosa traumatica che cazzo devo fare i
sto gioco c'è un colosso che mi segue
con un accetta e non ha senso allora
ricapitoliamo
abbiamo trovato un pupazzo inutile
abbiamo trovato un corpo si un corvo che
passava beh abbiamo trovato un pupazzo
inutile hagrid con un'accetta dopodiché
abbiamo trovato una porta chiusa che non
si riesce ad aprire e l'utilità di tutto
questo quale non lo so ma so che è colpa
tua brutto bastardo
vabbè da adesso in avanti dichiara
guerra agli orsacchiotti sappiatelo
dovrei riuscire a trovare qualcosa che
prima non altro tipo una chiave una
chiave per una porta di legno che l'ha
sfondata e state piuttosto ma vabbè
anzi quasi quasi ruberà il accetta con
il pezzente di merda in qualche modo
riuscire ad aprirla ma di sicuro ragazze
una chiave nascosta che non ho trovato
qua ci sono dei fiori che cazzo ci fanno
dei fiori così li segue
oddio ho trovato le gambe ho trovato
buongiorno sono sue
no allora le prendo io grazie ho trovato
delle scarpe che cazzo mi servono delle
scarpe che datemi un motivo non è che
quel tipo con l'accetta mi segue perché
cerca le scarpe non le trova allora bene
son traguardi questi o un paio di scarpe
e non ha paura ad usarle brutto stronzo
fatti vedere tu hai un accetta io ti
lancio gli scarponi in faccia vediamo
chi la vince ok
devo andare devo andare da quel che
probabilmente lo tornare di dentro anche
se non ho capito cosa ci può fare bene
noi entriamo c lo stesso allora ci
dovrebbe essere una chiave nascosta in
teoria da qualche modo cazzo aiuto dov'è
dove dai visto libro di merda che non
vedo dio che cazzo sono ancora vivo
sono ancora vivo dove cazzo andato era
qui non sono pazzo l'ho visto l'ho visto
era qui maledizione via cosa devo fare
qua troviamo una cazzo di chiave
immediatamente leviamoci dai [ __ ]
subito non ci sono chiari
è questa da dove cazzo e smontata perché
ho trovato una chiave perché datemi un
motivo ho trovato ragazzi l'ho fatta ho
trovate una [ __ ] chiave andiamo ad
aprire la porta di legno ce l'abbiamo
fatta
in compenso mi sono spariti gli scarponi
allora forse credo di aver capito il
tipo con l'accetta mi è venuto addosso
perché aveva perso i suoi scarponi della
nonna e gliel'ho ritrovati io e se n'è
andato perché ha preso di scarponi
perfetto e ho trovato anche la chiave
[Musica]
cos'era un mio zio di socrate cos'era
sto rumore di merda che cazzo
buongiorno c'è qualcuno che poi il razzo
quel muro era sfondato poteva entrarci
tranquillamente ma dettagli non fa nulla
vabbè andiamo avanti scavalchi a posto
scavare chiudi la porta prima che entra
coi pezzente cazzo mi significa tutto
questo
vabbè ragazza è un gioco finora senza
senso abbiamo trovato un orsacchiotto
che abbiamo messo su una sedia che aveva
acceso un fuoco
abbiamo trovato degli scarponi che
abbiamo ridato a un colosso con un
accetta e abbiamo trovato una che in
cambio ci ha dato una chiave
abbiamo aperto una porta che era
facilmente sfonda bile e stiamo andando
avanti c'è tutto questo casino
cos'è sta
[Musica]
sti cazzi del rotto complimenti che
cazzo dovrei cosa sei minos me lo
spieghi tu che cosa sei
posso avvicinarmi senza che mi stupri
che cos'è sta roba raga è un tipo seduto
in una posizione molto scomoda
porca [ __ ] ma cos'è ma x che devono
apparire le ombre a caso porca [ __ ]
cos'è sta scritta prima non c'era lui è
una guardia ceca trovami e ti aiuterò ti
trovo volentieri se so chi cazzo sei
anche perché finora incontrato anche
delle ombre che non mi stanno simpatiche
però non capisco che cosa devo fare qui
che posto di merda dove devo andare
che cazzo ma è caduto addosso ai tentato
brutto stronzo di merda stai tentando di
fottermi stai tentando di potervi brutto
va cos'è bar che brucia lo si ti brucio
brutto stronzo ti brucia perché stai
tentando di uccidermi da mezz'ora due
quel [ __ ] thor di merda non c'è un
accendino minchiatti va bene che non c'e
l'accendino che ti dava fuoco come non
so cosa hai tentato di uccidermi
bruciando mi hai tentato di gavi armi ai
tentato di mandarmi contro un colosso di
due metri e vivamente brutto stronzo che
prima o poi ci rivedremo ottieni momenti
io mi tengo d'occhio
ti tengo d'occhio ok direi di andar via
raga direi che devo bruciare
quell'affare di prima sono quasi sicuro
ma dato che lontano un chilometro direi
di tagliare ok raga perfetto era quello
che non mi aspettavo all'edizione devo
entrare qui dentro ma che cazzo tutta na
lei ritrovate le scarpe che cosa vuoi
ancora cosa vuoi te lo date le scarpe
telo date prima cosa vuoi
devo bruciare quel tizio inutile che vai
di là perché tanto devo bruciare quel
tizio senti non mi fare brutti scherzi
all'improvviso perché do fuoco anche a
te
raga stanno tentando di uccidermi in
qualsiasi lo so che l'orsacchiotto lo so
e inutile che me lo fate presente lo so
che è quel maledetto orsacchiotto di
merda lo so lo ucciderà prima o poi
tanto soffiato o che ci siamo
devo a perfetto le ho già dato fuoco di
mio cosa devo fare ancora ho messo la
tanica cioè come faccio a dargli fuoco
non c'è un accendino non c'è
senti allora partiamo col presupposto
che non sono tuo amico ma non è che
avresti da accendere
no perché devo dar fuoco a ma facciamo
finta che non ho detto niente
c'è una candela laga mi era venuto in
mente che c'era il fuoco qui prima se
riesco a trovare un cazzo di ramo magari
riesco a apprenderlo ecco i fatti ha
infatti ce l'ho fatta
ok lo trova ragazzi siamo ci siamo devo
riuscire a dar fuoco a quella roba è
e tutto in avanti indietro fino alla
porca [ __ ] praga preparatevi ai fuochi
d'artificio perché ci sarà da divertirsi
e non mi chiedete perché devo dar fuoco
a quella roba perché ancora non l'ho
capito
oddio lega sono ancora vivo mi ha
caricato tipo rugby
ok ragazzi siamo e non voglio sapere
dov'è andato cazzo brucia brutto stronzo
ok ci siamo ragazzi siamo alquanto scena
ok è apparsa una porta è apparsa una
porta senza motivo io ci entrò subito
prima di andare non mi dire che chiunque
perfetto capitolo 2 coming soon brutto
stronzo dimmi che non è finito qui
perché ti prendo a calci e dopo tutto
sto casino
mio dio non ci credo lago è finito qui
qualcosa cosa ho appena giocato raga
ditemi cosa ho appena giocato brutto
maledetto orsacchiotto di merda
da adesso in avanti io dichiaro guerra a
tutti gli os chiotti che ci sono perché
mi stanno sul culo a prescindere gli
orsacchiotti comunque va beh se il video
è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come noi
video trovate nella descrizione se non
siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo in un prossimo video bene
ragazzi